it is time for hatred mail quick
reminder about hatred mail because if
you aren't pro-life you deserve the
death penalty Patriot Man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom you know
this this is I guess this is pseudo left
hatred mail maybe in some sense let's
take a listen to it
hey PAC [ __ ] David's shill meter is off
the charts I'm sorry David like almost
everything you say you're clearly wrong
all the time
careful what you shall for David you may
end up regretting it when they take your
money you made the silencing of Tulsi a
reality you made is Biden's Warren
supports david hackman is a shill for
the Democratic establishment an AIP AC
and he has a really bad political
analysis listen guys tulsi ceiling is
literally 2 to 3 percent ok Tulsi was
polling 1 to 2 percent for months yang
got out mayor Pete got out amy klobuchar
got out Elizabeth Warren got out and
Tulsi still polling 2 to 3 percent
Tulsi lost yesterday to people who
aren't even running anymore in some of
the states the idea that I or anyone
else silenced her and were it not for us
her the the appeal of her ideas would
have been so overwhelming that she would
have won anything is absolutely
ridiculous it's this is the type of
delusional nonsense that just hurts the
movement and it distracts from getting
things done which is my priority
remember that you can fight hate reott
ism with the coupon code hatred for the8
e RI ot for zero you save 40% off of the
membership of your choice and hatreds
cry because they're patriotic pleas are
ignored and support for the David Pakman
show grows